welcome to the show good to be back in
the studio had a long Columbus Day
weekend maybe some stories from my
weekend later on in the week really
important to contextualize mass
shootings when they happen mass
shootings are tragic they're horrible
they expose some of the most significant
depravity that our country faces today
and there are connections between mass
shootings and endless legal and cultural
issues that the United States is facing
that I've been talking about for years
on the program but the shootings never
stop after a mass shooting in fact as of
yesterday starting on October 2nd right
the shooting in Las Vegas was in October
first starting on October 2nd through
yesterday there were 247 people killed
by guns in the United States that is
nearly five times the number that were
killed in Las Vegas on the evening of on
October 1st just some of them and we
could do I could read these for an hour
there's a woman who is not yet at least
facing charges after fatally shooting
her boyfriend in Indianapolis there are
two people who have been charged in the
fatal shooting of 19 year of a 19 year
old in Union New Jersey Richmond
Virginia police are investigating a
double homicide that happened in Shaco
Bottom Virginia early Sunday morning
I could list all 247 of these deaths
plus any that happened in the last few
hours I haven't checked in the last few
hours but the number might be even
higher in 2017 we've had a major mass
shooting about every couple of months
346 people estimated killed this year in
mass shootings more than a person a day
has been killed in the u.s. from mass
shootings over recent years and we
continue to see gun sales go up after
mass shootings and when we hear about
the conspiracy theories around these
mass shooting oh this was staged by
Obama or by I guess under Trump anti-gun
advocates who want to create a pretext
for the confiscation of guns we see guns
sale
go up after mass shootings if anybody
had an interest in mass shootings in
order to impact gun sales it would be
the pro-gun lobby right the NRA would
have an interest if anybody was going to
do a false-flag mass shooting in order
to impact gun sales it would be the NRA
because it's been widely demonstrated
that more guns are sold after these mass
shooting incidents and we always hear
the same tired arguments from the
pro-gun right hey David you know what
those statistics about gun deaths are
meaningless because most gun deaths are
suicides and those people are going to
kill themselves either way well first of
all you can accidentally not kill
yourself much easier with other methods
than with a gun right in other words you
can fail to commit suicide with other
types of methods much more easily than
you might fail with a gun secondly even
if you grant that a lot of the gun
deaths or suicides do we not care about
people who are killing themselves if we
had 100% background checks on every gun
transaction mandatory waiting periods as
well that would prevent some of those
suicides even either by making the guns
more difficult or less quick to obtain
or giving someone three four or five
days during which they might say hey you
know what instead of actually killing
myself I'm going to go look for help and
in fact we have data there's a very
common argument from the right which is
hey listen if you make guns more
difficult to buy people will just kill
themselves some other way there's a 2007
paper which looked at suicide rates in
Austrian firearms regulations and what
was found was that after legislation
mandated safe storage practices and a
three day waiting period for firearms as
well as both background and
psychological testing prior to purchase
and a requirement to be 21 years of age
they found a decline in the suicide rate
okay not in the suicide rate by gun in
the total suicide rate it does make a
difference another argument guns don't
kill people people kill people yeah
people kill people with guns and the
more deadly the gun
the more easy it is to obtain that gun
the more easily that those people can
kill other people with guns and then you
also hear hey if you make guns illegal
people will just get them illegally even
in Vegas if it had been more difficult
to get the guns right if buying 33 guns
in 13 months had triggered something in
our system it's very possible that the
shooter would have had fewer guns and
ended up killing fewer people and let's
also not forget about the single and
double double homicide incidents that
just lead to or rather attempted single
and double homicide incidents that lead
to endless injuries I'm not even getting
into those numbers so please do not fall
for the suicide fallacy and remember
that even though it's the mass shootings
that get the big coverage that lasts for
weeks
these single and double homicides are
actually the majority of those homicide
gun deaths and what what can we do right
can I report on it every single day
maybe I should maybe at the beginning of
every show I should go through a list of
everybody who's been killed by firearms
homicide since the last show would
people like that I don't know it's very
very difficult and it's particularly
difficult with the the news media cycle
that we have but don't think that it's
just the mass shootings that are leading
to people's deaths the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership